this the response to the government's
call to carry on as normal
cue upon queue of cars
the same scene up and down the country
despite reassurances drivers are lining
up nervous that fuel could run out
for some the long wait is too much to
bear
for others there's no choice but to sit
patiently i've got
15 miles of petrol left i'm a community
physio
i need petrol to do my job so i had to
go into the office twice this week and
so i was actually pretty much on empty
but i was on the phone my friend and he
was driving past the petrol station he
was saying about how kind of busy it was
is there petrol shortages
no
no
it's mad isn't it i know what people are
like because they tend to panic don't
they and then that causes the shortage
makes it all worse
we had that with the toilet roll with
coronavirus this petrol station near
reading has been inundated with drivers
panicking after another station up the
road ran out of fuel staff here tell me
they do have enough supplies which will
hopefully see them through the weekend
but that depends on how many more
drivers rush to the pumps oil companies
and retailers are keen to stress that
the problem with supply is small
bp says around 20 of its 1200 sites are
currently closed and up to 100 stations
are affected by the loss of at least one
grade of fuel
meanwhile tesco says only two of the 500
petrol stations it operates are
currently impacted other supermarkets
claim not to have any issues
there is no shortage of fuel the uk has
a very good supply of fuel at the moment
there's just an issue with a few um
sites having difficulty with getting
deliveries uh but panic buying is really
not going to help we'd really urge
people not to panic by otherwise it
could all become a kind of
self-fulfilling prophecy with food
shortages during the pandemic still raw
in people's minds many don't want to
risk a repeat with fuel
but rushing to fill up when you don't
need to is precisely what's causing
stations to close charlotte lomas sky
news